hi there Steve Kaufman here I've had a
bit of a mishap here at YouTube for some
reason I was persuaded that we should
have a partnership or some kind of an ad
deal with YouTube so we did that or
someone did that for me with the result
of my youtube videos show up with me
advertising busu or other online
language learning systems which I'm not
too keen do so I decided that we should
disengage from Adsense and the person
who helped me do that managed to delete
a whole bunch of videos including the
ones that are loaded up most recently so
we're now looking at ways that we can
recover those videos which is kind of
too bad because we're probably even if
we had can recover that we're going to
lose all the links to them and stuff
like that so that's not very good by the
way the t-shirt that I have on I
attended this TLC at the beach in Myrtle
Beach which had to do with literacy and
technology and so forth and so on but so
some of my videos are gone now I hope
that we can recover them I don't know at
any rate i'm going to start up again the
series that i started which is called
you know faq frequently asked questions
so i'll just put this one up as a brief
explanation if anybody has any advice on
how we can recover those videos that
would be greatly appreciated and i will
start again creating those frequently
asked questions videos so you all were
floundering around my wife's playing
down on the background and we're trying
to figure out how we can recover those
videos that were deleted
bye for now